Arthur hinderknech a confirmé cette
nouvelle sur les réseaux sociaux il
explique également sur ces réseaux
sociaux les raisons de son début de
saison poussifs depuis décembre il a
enchaîné le covid-19 la mononucléose et
la pub Alger à son retour de l'Open
Australie au total le Saint-Germain a
remporté que 5 matchs depuis janvier des
résultats qui l'ont fait descendre qui
l'ont fait redescendre à la 80e place
mondiale
et puis on continue avec bon comme tous
les jours il y en a il y avait une
menace aujourd'hui à Versailles tout à
fait plusieurs syndicats enseignants se
sont réunis place du marché Notre-Dame à
Versailles il dénonce le projet de
généralisation du du service national
universel SNU souhaité par le chef de
l'État Emmanuel Macron en déplacement
sur le stand SNUI Sarah l la secrétaire
d'État chargée de la jeunesse et du
service national universel a été
accueilli par un concert de casserole
alors si je vous parle de partir du jour
je subodore vous allez me dire 55 624
mais 55624 quoi il y a 55 624 c'est le
nombre de procès verbaux qui ont été
dressés sur l'année 2022 à Versailles
alors cela apparaît gros et pourtant
d'après nos confrères de l'hebdomadaire
toutes les nouvelles le nombre d'amande
aurait diminué de 3,24% par rapport à
l'année 2021 alors le but n'est pas de
dresser le plus d'amandes mais de
réduire les stationnements abusifs
d'après les propos de Jean-Pierre
Laroche de Roussan l'adjoint au maire de
Versailles et la recette globale pour
2022 s'élève après de 1 million 300000
euros pour la ville et puis il y en a
qui revient un petit peu cette covid le
covid en reparle et pour qu'on en
reparle alors on en reparle Patrice
alors on espère qu'il ne reviendra pas
mais justement ce jeudi démarre une
campagne de vaccination de rappel contre
le covid 19 elle concerne les personnes
les plus fragiles et dès l'automne une
autre campagne de rappel sera
recommandée à un plus large public
merci beaucoup Régis drache et on va
parler avec vous nos premiers habitudes
de la gendarmerie de la gendarmerie
couvre ses portes je l'ai dit c'était le
13 mai c'est ça
concerne évidemment toute
l'Île-de-France alors je vous présente
une major Christophe Carlier bonsoir
Patrice et vous êtes chef du centre
d'information et de recrutement de Paris
gendarmerie et chef d'escadron Aurore
Rigail vous êtes chef du bureau de
communication de la région gendarmerie
Île-de-France et c'est la preuve qui a
des femmes dans la gendarmerie il y a
des fraises
la gendarmerie féminisée à hauteur de
20% 20% de femmes dans la gendarmerie
c'est de plus en plus oui oui on a de
plus en plus de candidats féminines qui
qui souhaitent rentrer en gendarmerie
justement le 13 le 13 mai ça sera
l'occasion de leur montrer les
différents métiers que elles peuvent
prétendre au sein de la gendarmerie
alors on va voir qu'il y a
des dizaines de métiers différents à
l'intérieur de la gendarmerie on va
parler dans un instant mais est-ce que
il y a une spécificité des femmes ou des
hommes ou est-ce que vous faites
exactement les mêmes tâches alors c'est
les femmes et les hommes peuvent faire
exactement les mêmes métiers les mêmes
tâches au sein de la gendarmerie en
choisissant des spécialités en fonction
de leurs évolutions de carrière ou de
leur souhaits d'affectation et autres
donc elle gendarmerie propose exactement
aux hommes et aux femmes les mêmes
perspectives de carrière
alors vous êtes chef d'escadron vous
êtes major c'est quoi un major c'est un
escadron
dans le corps des sous-officiers j'ai
passé un concours
comme ceux que nous passons actuellement
et j'ai pu gravir tous les différents
grades jusqu'à atteindre ce grade de
majeur d'accord et
c'est le un grade
bière d'une carrière d'officier qui
commence à lieutenant pour ci par
capitaine chef d'escadron il y en a
colonel colonel
l'escogénale donc voilà c'est une
carrière d'officier alors par exemple
Christophe nous disiez vous aviez passé
un concours alors le concours de pour
être sous-officier directement oui tout
à fait alors c'est réservé à des à des
jeunes qui ont le baccalauréat qui ont
entre 18 et 35 ans et en fait après
cette inscrit sur le site de la
gendarmerie recrute.fr on va les
convoquer à des épreuves alors épreuves
d'admissibilité c'est une épreuve de
culture G et ensuite
en cas de réussite à cette épreuve
d'admissibilité ils vont entrer en
épreuve d'admission où là ils vont avoir
une épreuve de sport un entretien avec
un jury et si les notes sont bonnes et
que la moralité également
ils vont intégrer une école de
gendarmerie pour suivre une formation en
école de gendarmerie
pour ma part moi j'ai je suis
directement rentrée au grade d'officier
en passant le concours qui est qui est
ouvert aux universitaires titulaire de
Master 2 d'accord donc il y a un
concours qui permet d'intégrer
directement
l'école des officiers de gendarmerie
nationale 10 suivre une scolarité de 2
ans et de sortir ensuite au grade de
lieutenant pour aller commander une
unité élémentaire sur le territoire
métropolitain ou en autre mère j'ai des
escadron ça correspond à capitaine ou
pas non c'est le grade supérieur
c'est l'appellation
comme ça
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé je peux
passer un peu de questions personnelles
mais c'est intéressant qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à choisir la gendarmerie
qui veut commencer moi
c'était très simple c'était vraiment
pour la diversité des missions
aujourd'hui un jeune qui rentre en
gendarmerie peut donner une à son
parcours s'il veut travailler dans la
police judiciaire il faut un travail
dans le préjudiciaire dans la sécurité
dans le domaine de l'intervention le
nombre de possibilités un jeune peut
donner un vrai sens à son parcours bon
c'est aussi à lui de faire en sorte
qu'ils suivent les formations
nécessaires et proposer par le la
direction générale quand vous quand vous
avez passé le concours vous avez dit
pourquoi je veux être gendarme quoi en
fait je me suis dit je vais faire un
métier utile et je trouve un gendarme
c'est un métier qui est qui est vraiment
très utile et surtout qui travaille au
profit de la population et moi ces deux
éléments c'est de temps ces autres
points forts
c'est vraiment la raison pour laquelle
j'ai j'ai peu présenter le concours de
sous-office gendarmerie que j'ai réussi
et d'ailleurs je dis ça comme ça mais on
voit beaucoup parfois il y a des des
tensions entre la population la police
de façon générale il semble que les
gendarmes sont peut-être mieux acceptés
je sais pas pourquoi peut-être parce que
vous êtes plus dans des dans des zones
rurales aussi non oui la gendarmerie est
très implantée donc la gendarmerie est
importée sur 95% du territoire au
contact de la population dans beaucoup
de zones rurales mais pas que aussi au
contact de la population périurbaine
elle est bien souvent le dernier recours
en tout cas c'est un service ouvert 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 qui offre
qui propose une offre de sécurité mais
également une réponse à tout concitoyen
qui vient chercher une raison alors je
vous pose la même question que j'ai posé
à Christophe vous vous êtes dis donc au
Master 2 c'est ça et
vous êtes donc une femme et vous dites
voilà je voudrais dire gendarme
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé ça alors la multiplicité des
possibilités en fait en termes
d'évolution de carrière la gendarmerie
offre à peu près 300 métiers dans
lesquels on peut évoluer
que ce soit sur la partie dirigeante
donc moi j'ai choisi plutôt un métier
d'officier qui est plutôt dans la
direction
l'accompagnement et le commandement de
personnel voilà exactement le management
et
cela dans 300 métiers dans autant de
spécialités sur tout le territoire
métropolitain et en outre-mer ce qui
offre quand même pour une carrière des
possibilités énormes notamment
en termes d'évolution en termes de de
possibilités de mobilité et de
changement également de d'un métier à
l'autre voilà alors une question de
structure alors vous êtes des
des des gens de l'armée enfin des
soldats enfin vous déposer de l'armée
mais vous dépendez du ministère de la
Défense ou du ministère de l'intérieur
on sait plus maintenant des deux hein
statutairement du ministère des armées
donc nous avons statut de militaire et
tout ce qui concerne l'emploi est mis à
la main du ministère de l'Intérieur
une sorte de regroupement un peu entre
la gendarmerie et la police il y a eu
des tensions par le passé il y a moins
aujourd'hui je vais vous faire parler de
ça parce que c'est un sujet un peu
compliqué
vous faites cette journée portes
ouvertes donc ça veut dire je suppose
que il y a des besoins de recrutement il
y a des besoins de recrutement
effectivement les les comme dans
beaucoup d'administrations nous avons
des besoins de recrutement nous avons
besoin de
de montrer en fait à la jeunesse les
multiples perspectives de carrière tous
les métiers
qui existent en gendarmerie parce que
bien souvent l'image de la gendarmerie
se résume à
l'image d'un gendarme peut-être au bord
de la route ou en tout cas ce qui peut
être montré
ce qu'on voit le plus c'est ça c'est les
gendarmes
bonjour vous avez on va parler avec vous
tout à l'heure dans quelques instants
c'est la sécurité routière c'est ce
qu'on voit plus souvent mais il y a les
brigades territoriales par exemple
brigade territoriale c'est quoi
territoriale c'est une une brigade qui
est assure un accueil du public et
surtout qui assure une surveillance de
son territoire donc qui a compétence sur
une circonscription c'est un ensemble de
communes et les territoires qui sont
rattachés et qui assure la prévention
des atteintes au bien et aux personnes
sur ce territoire en lien avec les élus
et tous les acteurs du territoire donc
ce sont des personnels que l'on voit
très souvent également alors le peloton
de surveillance et d'intervention ça
c'est plus alors ça c'est davantage une
unité d'appui qui vient au renfort et en
appui de l'abrigade territoriale donc
plutôt spécialisée dans l'intervention
comme ça
il y a des unités de police judiciaire
ça qui font des autres enquêtes je
suppose
les ça c'est assez nouveau je pense
lutte contre les atteintes à
l'environnement et à la santé alors
c'est pas proprement nouveau mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un focus un peu plus
poussé depuis les annonces du ministre
de l'intérieur mais il y a toujours eu
en fait des des gendarmes spécialisés
dans la la les atteintes à
l'environnement parce qu'on est quand
même sur une réglementation un peu plus
particulière en tout cas poussée et nous
sommes en train de développer le nombre
de ces enquêteurs qui sont en mesure de
relever les infractions et de poursuivre
les les contrevenants qui viendraient
apporter
de nouvelles coups contreventions
notamment enfin de nouvelles infractions
contre contre les attentes à
l'environnement il y a une mission alors
ça c'est ton outre-mer mais c'est un
très titre parce que c'est un titre un
peu ancien la gendarmerie prévauta là
c'est ça absolument alors ce n'est pas
notre mère c'est la gendarmerie alors ça
peut être en outre-mer mais c'est
surtout sur les théâtres d'opération
extérieure en fait la gendarmerie est
présente partout où il ne force
militaire armée et déployée il y a des
forces de gendarmerie et c'est la
mission de la gendarmerie prévautale
d'accord donc ça c'est voilà non alors
on va vite évidemment mais déjà on voit
qu'il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
de fonctions possibles et extrêmement
différente des unes des autres il y a
évidemment l'autre montagne ça on le
voit avec les hélicoptères souvent qui
qui viennent chercher tout à fait les
gens qui sont perdus ou des gens qui
sont des unités spécialisées en secours
aux personnes les forces aériennes aussi
absolument nous avons des pilotes
d'hélicoptères des mécaniciens qui
travaillent au sein de la Force aérienne
de la gendarmerie pour assurer la
surveillance 3D mais également l'appui
aux unités terrain sur des recherches de
personnes sur des opérations divers
[Musique]
17 ans à 35 ans avec la nationalité
française d'accord donc à partir
de préférence
mais en fait il faut surtout tout le
monde peut trouver sa place au sein de
la gendarmerie l'idée c'est vraiment
bien se renseigner donc pour ça vous
avez des centres d'information de
recrutement vous avez aussi cette
journée du 13 mai qui va permettre à ces
jeunes de bien se renseigner et en
venant
des rencontres
bien se renseigner c'est quasiment être
certain de faire un métier qui
correspond vraiment à ce que l'on
recherche
on doit pas se rendre on doit pas se
tromper
on s'engage pour combien de temps quand
on s'engage en fait quand vous êtes
recruté vous partez à la limite d'âge de
votre grade donc c'est gratuit
s'orienter on les accompagne d'ailleurs
on a une cellule de reconversion pour ça
mais l'idée c'est quand même de regarder
est-ce que vous avez eu peur de temps en
temps dans l'exercice de votre métier il
peut arriver dans l'exercice du métier
d'avoir effectivement des moments un
petit peu plus difficiles que d'autres
mais la plupart du temps on n'est pas
seul et la force du collectif on est
souvent à deux trois quand on est en
gendarmerie mobile on est au sein d'un
peu le ton cette force du collectif est
que bien souvent la peur est ressentie
après mais voilà le côté solidaire
qui fait partie qui fait donc des
actions avec des des voilà mon petit
terroriste soit soit sur des sur des
terrains d'action très très difficile et
ben merci merci infiniment donc au
rappel 13 mai Maisons-Alfort c'est toute
la journée je crois 10h 17h voilà
parfait
parce que on va aborder un sujet
passionnant avec Emmanuel bonjour
vous êtes le PDG le fondateur de ce
qu'elle importe
en français exactement
et là qui développe
mauvais on dit alors
voilà ouais c'est une plateforme qu'on a
créé alors que si les technologies merci
c'est vraiment notre spécialité
technologie immersive alors je dis en
deux mots pour voilà pour qu'on soit au
courant cette c'est la réalité virtuelle
au service de la santé
en schématisant un peu sachant
qu'effectivement nous on est aussi très
avancé sur les technologies de réalité
virtuelle sans casque
ou le principe de cette technologie là
c'est que vous allez au lieu de vous
isoler dans un casque avec une image 3D
devant les yeux on va projeter ces
images sur des murs et du coup on va
libérer l'utilisateur de d'un casque
avec qui peut être encombrant oxygène et
on va lui mettre des lunettes 3D au
cinéma
ce qui fait qu'on va aussi être
compatible pour les enfants dès l'âge de
6 ans et ça nous ouvre justement un
potentiel sur Moover en particulier qui
est un outil de traitement des troubles
de l'apprentissage de l'apprentissage
notamment dyslexie notamment notamment
les sexy au départ vous vous faites du
gaming non oui
parce qu'on va parler on va parler de
concours de jeux vidéo tout à l'heure
au départ c'est ça au départ c'est
exactement ça on est une bande de gamer
chez skelwan clairement vous êtes à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et puis un jour
on a une orthoptiste qui nous appelle à
la tenté elle dit je sais pas si ça se
fait d'appeler une société comme ça elle
nous appelle et j'ai vu vos jeux j'ai
peut-être des idées et donc elle est
venue nous voir à venait de Rouen un
vendredi soir à 21h je serai toujours on
était avec Julien à mon associé et puis
là on a commencé à phosphorer et
imaginer effectivement des jeux et
finalement le jeu est important parce
que génère de la dopamine pour les
enfants en particulier et donc j'ai un
facteur de motivation supplémentaire
dans la thérapie et
la technologie qu'on avait développé qui
est sans casque son périphérique
permettait de mettre des interactions
simples mais efficaces
et
donc voilà on a travaillé ça avec
Charlotte Gibert donc orthoptiste à
Rouen qui est de qui est depuis à
rejoindre en tant que thérapeute
référente le projet et voilà et on a
créé ces jeux là on a créé des jeux
spécialisés
enfin spécialement conçu pour pour
régler enfin vous pour essayer de
d'améliorer le des voilà des enfants qui
sont instants dyslexie de
dysfonctionnements voilà exactement on
va traiter tous les troupes cognitifs au
sens large donc à la dyslexie dyspraxie
il y a aussi les troubles de l'attention
on a on a des thérapeutes qui traitent
les autistes aussi
tout ce qui est décisionnel troubles de
l'équilibre une façon qu'on est vertige
et donc voilà c'est vrai qu'on a
vraiment créé une plateforme immersive
qui est une sorte de smartphones
vraiment grande taille du thérapeute sur
lequel on ajoute des applications et ses
applications vont tout et tout avoir une
fonction très spécifique pour adresser
voilà une certaine pathologie de manière
plus ou moins ludique en fonction
effectivement de ce qu'on doit faire
justement comment comment est-ce que une
personne atteinte d'une pathologie peut
utiliser ces technologies qu'elle passe
par un médecin ou alors nous on équipe
que les thérapeutes d'accord clairement
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout sur un
outil grand public on installe un écran
3 mètres de large une projection 3
mètres de large en 3D dans le cabinet du
thérapeute là on va en avoir deux là
dans 78
le premier donc qui est installé en
cours depuis le mois d'octobre et là on
en installe un Montfort-l'Amaury très
prochainement et les résultats sont très
prometteurs
c'est au-delà de ce qu'on pouvait
espérer clairement au début même on
était même c'était un peu
on en rigole avec Charlotte aux dépens
on disait bon Charlotte tu as des idées
voilà elle avait des résultats on nous
racontait quand même des histoires un
petit peu dignes de Lourdes c'est-à-dire
des gamins qui avaient pas du tout à
lire et qui se retrouvent en intensif à
avoir un déclic en allez 5 6 séances et
en suivant la thérapie finalement en 6
mois plus tard gagner le rallye lecture
du collège
et on a une première histoire comme ça
une deuxième une troisième on a ça chez
le thérapeute et tout c'est tout nous
disent ben ouais on a ce genre de
résultat en fait c'est une merveilleuse
histoire pour vous ah c'est génial non
non
c'est très bien faire du gaming mais
quand on est en plus enfin quand on sait
qu'on peut avoir une utilité comme ça
c'est vous utilisez vous de la réalité
virtuelle on utilise ce stade aussi
poussé mais effectivement dans les
formations de nos élèves gendarmes ou
élève officiers on utilise
game ou quelques choses qui peut
s'apparenter à la réalité augmentée
justement pour les faire travailler dans
des cassimulés etc sans forcément mis en
danger ou déploiements sur le terrain
oui mais vous continuez les autres
activités alors on a toujours un fond
d'activité effectivement sur parce que
on est quand même expert maintenant
toutes ces technologies là n'existent
depuis 2014 on travaille avec des gros
industriels
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce projet Moover a été construit sur la
base d'une technologie d'un produit
qu'on avait surtout dessiné aux salles
de jeux américaines à la base qui était
du jeu pur donc oui on a cette habitude
le produit gaming effectivement depuis
la face covid a clairement décliné et
puis aussi on focalise aussi nos
activités pour pour vraiment
mettre notre coeur de l'effort je dirais
dans le déploiement de mouvoir qui qui
aide vraiment qui a une vraie vocation
je dirais à aider et je dirais même
philosophiquement on va dire parce qu'on
accuse beaucoup les écrans notamment un
d'être responsables notamment des
problèmes de troubles de la tension des
enfants en particulier et nous on essaie
de réutiliser la technologie encore un
peu plus avancée pour essayer de
corriger ça donc
on est vraiment content
on est 8 personnes à temps plein et on a
trois secrets en 2014 on a une petite
société qui est autofinancée aujourd'hui
et voilà et on a pu aussi la financer
parce que on a aussi des grands groupes
comme Renault en particulier qui nous
fait qui nous a beaucoup sollicité sur
sur de la des projets de R&D là on a
travaillé avec Dacia on a travaillé avec
EDF on a travaillé à sa forme d'acteurs
par notre expertise en fait et là encore
toujours avec un tout petit peu de
gamification dans les usages parce que
c'est vraiment une attente globale
finalement d'une génération qui arrive
sur avec les codes du gaming sur le
marché du travail qui a besoin
finalement de les retrouver
d'anticiper je dirais dans au collège
c'est une histoire magnifique je trouve
qui vous arrive et qui arrive grâce à
vous bon pourquoi ce qu'elle voit mon
portable alors ouais c'est pas le nom le
plus le plus facile à comprendre
quand on a créé la société en fait on
avait créé justement cet embryon de
moovers que vous avez pu voir tout à
l'heure avec ce portail qu'on appelle à
l'échelle 1 parce qu'on est spécialiste
de l'échelle d'accord quand on va mettre
dans un monde virtuel un objet qui fait
un mètre vous pourriez le mesurer avec
un mètre ruban il fera un mètre quand
vous allez mesurer c'est de là qui était
venu l'idée en fait le nom de la société
bravo merci beaucoup j'avais juste une
question pardon j'avais oublié de vous
demander j'avais envie de vous demander
parce que ça peut intéresser quand même
les gens qui voudraient tomber
est-ce qu'on peut avoir une vie de
famille tout en étant gendarmes ou
est-ce que bien sûr
possible d'avoir une vie de famille nous
deux nous en avons une
le gendarme en fait la plupart du temps
est logé par la gendarmerie et habite
sur son lieu de travail et l'hébergement
le logement accueille toute la famille
et adapté aux charges de famille donc
c'est même plutôt facilitant d'accord je
vous remercie je vous remercie de nous
avoir présenté alors évidemment mauvais
et puis ces journées du 13 mai
Maisons-Alfort vous faites évidemment
des gestes de premier urgence ou de
premiers secours
de premiers secours
de premiers secours et chaque jour cette
semaine et bon vous présente un geste de
premiers secours avec la croix blanche
78 et aujourd'hui c'est la position
latérale vous connaissez ça vous moi je
connais pas donc je vais regarder avec
très très très fortement la position
latérale de sécurité c'est Julien le roi
qui nous dit tout
[Musique]
dans cette séquence on va aborder la
conduite à tenir à avoir face à une
personne qui est inconsciente mais qui
respire là j'arrive près de
d'un jeune qui est sur le sol je regarde
effectivement s'il y a un saignement
important non et là je vais commencer à
vérifier s'il parle tu m'entends
sers-moi la main qui des yeux et là pas
de réaction la victime est donc
inconsciente il va falloir qu'on bascule
la tête en arrière pour libérer les
voisins aériennes en fait la scolarité
est inconsciente elle est bien plus
molle que lorsqu'elle dort tellement
molle qu'effectivement la langue a
tendance à descendre le problématique
c'est qu'effectivement ce qui est dans
son ventre et très liquide ça peut
sortir il peut se mettre à vomir et là
si il vomit les sécrétions gastriques
peuvent descendre dans la gorge et comme
ils respirent ça allait dans les poumons
il va mourir noyer dans son vomi donc il
faut le mettre sur le côté pour cela on
commence on va retirer les lunettes pour
préserver le visage rassemblez les
jambes le bras qui est de notre côté on
va le mettre faire deux angles droits
vers le haut pour libérer l'articulation
faire l'affaire circulation sanguine se
fasse bien prendre la main opposée la
mettre contre son oreille ça va garder
la tête on les voit rien libérées le
temps du retournement soulevez le genou
extérieur pour faire un bras de levier
et donc sans effort même si la victime
est plus lourde que nous en appuyant sur
le genou ça tourne tout seul ma main
bloquée je la retire en retenant son
coude j'enlève le masque je j'ouvre sa
bouche pour que les sécrétions
gastriques sanguines et salivaires
puissant d'aller et là je vais
stabiliser le bassin en mettant l'axe
genou hanche perpendiculaire au ventre
on va couvrir la victime avec un pull
une couverture de survie pour la
préserver donc des intempéries et
préserver sa température corporelle
on prévient les secours pour dire que la
victime est en position latérale de
sécurité et on va surveiller il faut
vérifier qu'il continue à ventiler
t'inquiète pas les secours vont arriver
les victimes qui entendent tout jusqu'à
l'hôpital donc on continue à leur parler
je vais mettre la main sur votre ventre
et là il faut qu'on puisse sentir les
mouvements du ventre pour s'assurer que
la victime respire et donc assurer la
surveillance jusqu'à l'arrivée des
secours
voilà la position latérale de sécurité
qui n'a plus aucun secret pour nous on
va pouvoir aller dans un instant avec
vous d'un direjuna bonjour
vous êtes réalisateur que vous êtes
surtout l'organisateur du tournoi des
cités fantastiques ados ado à chaque ado
ça veut dire vibration en japonais c'est
ça c'est ça et qui va avoir lieu à cet
endroit qui aura lieu du 24 au 29 sur
Skype
vous allez nous parler de ça parce que
évidemment j'ai beaucoup de jeunes là on
parlait de la réalité virtuelle vous
avez vu c'est intéressant qui peut être
utilisé pour la santé là on reste dans
le gaming dans le jeu dans la réalité
augmentée et réalité augmentée là avec
le casque avec un casque mais qui qui se
projette dans la réalité donc qui
augmente la réalité on voit on se voit
les uns les autres mais on augmente la
réalité très bien on va en parler dans
quelques instants Céline Charles bonsoir
alors vous avez fait la sélection des
films qu'il faut aller voir cette
semaine exactement des un thriller et
deux comédies voilà oui des belles
sorties cette semaine
mais auparavant on va s'intéresser à un
garçon qui s'appelle de Youri Kadia il y
aurait cadial et paraplégique et
pourtant pongiste c'est la preuve qu'on
peut voilà on peut surmonter son
handicap et c'est l'épreuve que même en
situation de handicap on peut prendre
soin de soi c'est un sujet que vous
verrez dans cette émission qu'on diffuse
qui s'appelle les yeux de Morgan qui est
consacré aux personnes atteintes de
handicap et c'est un sujet de Julien
Leroy
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ma salle de bain c'est là
je me prépare tous les matins de l'autre
côté du miroir afin de faire tomber les
préjugés pour Yorick de haut niveau et
comédien parisien de 35 ans prendre soin
de soi est un rituel quotidien suite à
un accident de moto en 2010 l'homme est
devenu paraplégique malgré son handicap
avoir une bonne image de soi reste pour
lui indispensable entre de la barbe
parfum et un petit secret beauté l'huile
de ricin pour coller le cheveu a même le
crâne caché la calvitie et puis en même
temps essayer de donner un petit volume
en fait c'est mon regard à moi qui me
qui me préoccupe c'est ce que moi ça me
plaît si ça me plaît pas non ça me
plaira pas aux gens par contre si ça me
plaît bon bah ça va ça va du coup
influencer ma confiance en moi handicapé
à 78% Yorick ajal tient à valoriser ses
capacités physiques restantes en tirant
une force de sa paraplégie il décide de
ne pas subir sa vie et de conserver son
optimisme pour comprendre ces nouveaux
projets j'ai des potes qui se laissent
aller qui sortent pas de chez eux qui
sont en mode ouais c'est handicapé donc
oui de toute façon quoi ça me sert de
mettre des godasses alors que j'ai pas
de sensations tu vois c'est et puis mes
pieds elles sont sur ma palette elle
bouge pas
et mon relevé les défis à intégrer
l'équipe de France Handisport comme
pongiste depuis deux ans il s'entraîne
dans cette salle de Voisins le
bretonneux quatre fois par semaine même
sur le terrain le sportif tient à
renvoyer une bonne image de lui à son
concurrent
[Musique]
mais le style et la façon dont on a
habillé renvoie quelque chose à
l'adversaire ça renvoie quelque chose au
regard extérieur c'est celui qui te
regarde à la caméra que celui le
spectateur le téléspectateur peu importe
il voit donc c'est comment tu te situes
on en revient à si tu t'apprécies toi si
tu aimes ce que tu portes si tu aimes
comme tu es si tu t'aimes les gens
t'aimeront de cette même manière là tu
vois Yorick a déjà le participe
actuellement à des tournois
internationaux pour espérer se qualifier
aux Jeux Olympiques 2024 il sera d'ici
un an si son vœu est exaucé une occasion
de faire bonne figure sur le plan
sportif et esthétique
apprendre à s'aimer apprendre à prendre
soin de soi c'est très important pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
pourtant pour tout le monde aussi et
puisqu'on parlait des yeux de Morgan il
se trouve que
Morgane Legrand qui présente cette
émission était venu ici et je l'avais
interviewé et justement elle est
atteinte de céciter et pourtant elle
l'aime comme elle va le recompter dans
cet extrait dessiner et courir vous ayez
décidé et vous aimez toujours décider
oui oui c'est un peu atypique vous
faites bien d'en parler mais
effectivement j'adorais dessiner des
portraits aux fusain je le fais un tout
petit peu moins parce que ça me demande
beaucoup de concentration et de fatigue
visuelle et que le potentiel visuel a
abaissé mais j'adore toujours en tout ce
qui est artistique l'histoire de l'art
même en ne voyant plus ça me passionne
toujours au service de l'espace entre
les doigts c'est ça pour pour mesurer
la taille d'un visage ou je sais pas oui
tout à fait pour bien mesurer l'espace
sur la feuille les proportions etc voilà
il y a des petites astuces bien
pratiques comme
ça
peut-être un peu dommage de pas voir le
dessin qu'on a fait vous le sentez ou
vous le sentez peut-être tel qu'il est
alors c'est vrai que ça un peu frustrant
alors il existe des stylos en relief que
je n'ai pas encore testé et sur le côté
ne pas voir le dessin et ben disons que
je m'auto persuade je me dis oh ça doit
être réussi voilà c'est un avantage tout
à fait vous faites aussi de la course à
pied oui vous aimez bien ça oui c'est
vrai j'ai couru en binôme j'ai eu cette
cette chance et c'est super alors
intéressant mais aussi comment immersif
puisque les réflexes l'environnement
alors tout change quand on ne voit pas
et voilà ça permettait aussi de
retrouver de la liberté et plein de
sensations donc bien sûr c'est super la
course à pied
voilà c'était Morgane Legrand Nadir
Yulin le tournoi des cités fantastiques
en ado ado rappelez-nous ce que je
connais pas tous le japonais
ça veut dire vibration en japonais pour
un peu les aficionados qui ont joué à
une certaine époque ou qui joue encore à
un jeu très connu qui s'appelle Street
Fighter les personnages faisaient des
Hadoken en fait ils envoient des boules
d'énergie de vibrations même pour les
femmes
on les voit il y a pas en fait alors le
tournoi il est autour du Hado le Hado
c'est le premier sport d'équipe au monde
en réalité augmentée la réalité
augmentée c'est-à-dire qu'on se voit on
est tous ensemble d'ailleurs ces équipes
de trois contre trois inclusifs
accessible aux personnes en situation de
handicapés
et en fait on a un casque et un capteur
de mouvement on est dans une arène où
disons qu'il y a des il y a des capteurs
répond un petit peu partout et en fait
dès qu'on fait un mouvement on génère
une boucle d'énergie comme un kamehameha
dans Dragon Ball Z en gros c'est une
savante combinaison entre Dragon Ball Z
et une balle au prisonniers et donc on
envoie une boule d'énergie ou alors on
fabrique en de manière en réalité
augmentée donc comme on holographique
comme un hologramme un bouclier comme
dans Black Panther afin de contrer les
boules d'énergie qui viennent de
l'équipe adverse on fabrique des
boucliers pour son équipe on se joue
comme du squatch en match très intense
donc des manches très courts d'une année
c'est très physique c'est très sportif
il y a beaucoup de sportifs qui viennent
jouer et qui participent au tournoi des
adultes et des et des et des plus jeunes
à chaque fois ils sont très étonnés de
l'intensité du jeu et donc c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est à dire que c'est
une combinaison entre le développement
du jeu d'un spot et du pur physiologique
avec et avec tout ce que ça amène dans
le côté innovation quel âge les joueurs
à partir de 7 ans
à partir de 17 ans on fait des combinés
on fait souvent des nous le tourment on
le règle entre 7 et 11 ans 11-15 ans 15
ans et demi
on a fait aussi des des tournois
plus amicaux avec
intergénérationnel avec les seniors et
les plus jeunes et ça marche très bien
et ça marche très bien et même les
parents viennent on fait des des petites
manches un peu
amicales comme tout à fait ou les
parents peuvent jouer avec les enfants
ou face aux enfants ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi que on n'est pas
contraint par une imitation physique
c'est pas parce qu'on est un grand
gaillard qu'on va gagner on va gagner
l'année dernière il y avait trois jeunes
filles qui ont qui qui ont remporté face
une équipe de de trois jeunes qui
étaient très fort mais peut-être qu'ils
se croyaient un peu trop un peu plus
fort que ce qui n'était et la vivac
c'est l'intelligence la stratégie de jeu
en équipe l'esprit d'équipe aussi a fait
que les les trois jeunes filles qui
étaient beaucoup plus menu on remporté
le remporté on remporté on remporté le
match tout à fait alors ça commence le
24 donc on court après il y a oui la
verrière
et la finale et finalement le 29
absolument attrape la salle
Jean-Baptiste
à chaque fois des équipes disqualifient
tout à fait il y a des dans chaque ville
on va dans chaque ville et on permet
donc aux participants de créer leurs
équipes donc souvent en plus ils
prennent des noms d'équipe de mandats
etc
c'est festif quoi très fun et du coup
chaque dans chaque ville il y a une
partie des équipes qui sont qualifiées
et à la fin on a la finale qui se qui se
joue donc dans une ville cette année
cette trappe qui nous fait plaisir de
l'accueillir de rien la finale et
l'encours nous a fait le plaisir de nous
accueillir je dois dire que on a de la
chance que les villes à Skype la
verrière Maurepas et l'oncle trappes ont
joué le jeu de l'innovation du eSport et
m'ont fait confiance j'ai fait mes
séries
et donc il y a alors il y a évidemment
le gaming d'abord je voulais dire de
choses c'est la première c'est que vous
êtes labellisé
olympique culturel par le comité Paris
2024 absolument on a eu cette chance là
c'est important tout à fait on a eu
cette chance là en fait quand on a lancé
au début de manière totalement neutre
indépendante sans rien justement les
villes de Sky ont joué le jeu ils m'ont
fait confiance ça a bien marché et
derrière on a eu on a eu cette
reconnaissance avec des soutiens de la
région Île-de-France et une
certification une labellisation
olympiade culturelle et du coup le
tournoi maintenant le temps fort il y a
un temps fort qui commence toujours par
Skype et après il y a un déploiement un
peu dans toute la France on l'a fait
jusque Marseille à Marseille la Paris
18e Paris 19e de Pierrefitte pas voilà
mais c'est vous qui l'avez créé c'est
nous qui avons créé ce tournoi et le but
en fait
ma vocation en tant que cinéaste déjà
j'avais la curiosité toujours comme
fidèle compagnon et étant étant vraiment
impliqué dans mon quartier que ce soit
le bois de l'étang trap et en cours et
les autres quartiers ils ont des
environs c'était de créer du capital
culturel et pour créer du capital
culturel j'ai bien j'ai bien senti que
la fracture numérique s'imposait qu'il y
avait une forme de jet lag c'est ça
parce que vous dites d'autres notre
mission c'est justement de de fracturer
la fracture la fracture numérique
absolument c'est à dire que
c'est un peu on a lancé d'abord les
cités fantastiques qui a un parcours en
réalité virtuelle ou le but c'est de ça
s'appliquer sur les technologies
d'avenir vous venez et vous découvrez ce
que c'est que la réalité virtuelle créer
des métamons ce que c'est que la réalité
augmentée ce que c'est que
l'holographique distinguer travailler et
j'ai très vite compris que si vous
voulez
[Musique]
c'est les deux missions
absolument mais bravo
en plus vous en parlez très très bien
moi je joue
pas
je m'entraîne pas assez je me suis trop
penché sur le terrain voilà mais je suis
intéressé par par même à terme pouvoir
développer nos propres technologies avec
des jeux qui ont des références
culturels c'est à dire que c'était
important de comprendre cette
technologie de comprendre que derrière
il y a de la création artistique est
possible mais il y a également du
business il y a de l'entrepreneuriat et
ça les jeunes qui viennent participer on
essaie toujours d'aller toucher sur ça
c'est à dire que demain tu peux
appartient que tu comprends une
interface de réalité augmentée ou de
réalité virtuelle faut pas se faire
intimider par les mots un mot c'est de
la langue française aussi de la langue
anglaise c'est tout et derrière les mots
et ben en fait il y a des il y a des
séquences à comprendre et c'est faisable
c'est accessible et il y a plein de
choses à déployer que ce soit on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans la santé comme ce
soit dans l'univers de l'éducation que
ce soit dans l'univers du tourisme en
fait dans l'univers du cinéma qui est
mon univers de prédilection mais en tous
les cas il y a plein d'éléments à
développer et qui sont aujourd'hui
accessibles et à l'intersection de tout
cela aujourd'hui on a l'intelligence
artificielle la réalité augmentée la
réalité virtuelle les jeunes ils peuvent
s'en emparer le monde qui arrive c'est
ça ils peuvent son pareil ils doivent
s'en emparer je pense que cette image
virtuelle tout ça tout ça vous passionne
absolument absolument c'est un passionne
et en même temps pour moi ça peut être
aussi
des leviers des tremplins parce qu'il y
a il y a parfois on veut créer en tant
qu'artiste assez librement et il y a des
outils comme ça qui viennent et qui nous
permettent de
scinder des de rapprocher des des corps
de métiers et du coup en tant créatif
des populations
ça absolument et c'est absolument
favorable c'est un lien social aussi
quoi tout à fait on a été voir quelques
enfants qui ont essayé
le ado on va regarder la réaction au
pied nous allons parler après
dans le vide le fait de lancer des
boules sur nos adversaires et comment
les lancer j'ai trouvé que c'était bien
là c'est pas le personnage qu'on a dans
le jeu c'est nous le personnage du coup
bah j'ai aimé ce fait
de metaves et voilà c'est la mode et en
fait là tout de suite si vous voulez
l'interface quand je vous mets le casque
vous voyez le terrain dans lequel vous
êtes vous voyez vos coéquipiers sauf
qu'on ajoute des couches un peu comme
Pokémon vous voyez un Pokémon dans la
rue ben là on voit des des couches on
voit son bouclier on voit et il y a une
interface un peu de jeux vidéo et sauf
que vous êtes le player vous êtes le
joueur et vous êtes acteur du jeu
réellement physiquement dans vos
mouvements donc
dans ce lien là c'est pour ça que c'est
passionnant parce que on est dans c'est
pas la société de demain c'est déjà la
société d'aujourd'hui
mais mais qui peut-être très perturbo
pour ce matin très changeante par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu enfin
on est là pour ça pour
bien par le jeu aussi d'apprendre de
pénétrer dans cette société qui va qui
va être la nôtre merci merci
donc je rappelle à 24 du 24 89 ça
commençait une course à finir à tram
mais finalement peuple le 29
l'inauguration
parce qu'en plus le le match donc les
matchs se jouent en live et dans dans
toute l'installation qu'on a les matchs
sont projetés sur un écran géant et donc
sur l'écran géant vous voyez la même
chose que ce que les les joueurs voient
c'est-à-dire vous voyez les la réalité
augmentée vous voyez les hologrammes
de timing du match vous encourager et
vous ont les gens encouragent leur
équipe les conseils un peu vraiment on
est un peu comme dans un finalement dans
un match de boxe ou un match de basket
ou de foot et d'ailleurs moi je trouve
que c'est très bien le foot c'est
formidable mais mais l'idée aussi
c'était de
pousser les jeunes vers des nouveaux
sports qui existent sur lesquels on sait
qu'en Île-de-France et un des viviers de
talents mondiaux pour le foot et moi je
pense que ça peut être un demain un
vieux talon aussi pour les ados et le
eSport de manière générale le sport est
un sport après
une culture et vraiment nous sur sur la
2 ce qui est bien c'est on a un versant
physique et c'est ça aussi qui nous a
permis d'avoir la labellisation
Olympiades culturelle c'est à dire qu'on
était vraiment singulier
merci beaucoup parce qu'on va parler de
cinéma donc ça c'est intéressant
qui vous avez fait la sélection des
films il y a de nombreux films qui
sortent cette semaine vous en avez
sélectionné trois donc on commence
peut-être par un thriller et oui tout à
fait il s'agit de misanthrope de Damian
zifronn alors rien à voir avec la pièce
de Molière l'histoire se concentre ici
sur Eleanor Falco une policière à la
psychologie très instable qui collabore
avec le FBI pour appréhender un tireur
fou qui multiplie les massacres aux
états
Woodley qui l'interprète qui interprète
l'héroïne et elle partage la fiche avec
Ben Mendelssohn en chef chevronné du FBI
regardez il y a 29 victimes
chacun de ces tirs a fait mouche
pas de douille
par un seul cheveu ou la moindre
empreinte
il ne veut pas mourir et il ne veut
surtout pas être retrouvé nous allons le
décevoir
je vais bosser pour le FBI
le FBI n'a pas voulu de faux
l'évaluation psychologique vous a fait
échouer agressive addictive et
antisocial c'est le profil des personnes
qu'on emprisonne pas qu'on engage je
pense que vous avez de l'instinct
transformez-le en carburant pour
alimenter de nouvelles théories tout de
suite un thriller policier plein de
tension qui s'est renouvelé le genre le
réalisateur en profite d'ailleurs pour
dénoncer les violences systémiques qui
gangrènent l'Amérique il est question
par exemple de législation autour du
port d'armes alors autre rendez-vous
c'est une comédie qui est signée Andrea
Bescond et
Eric Métayer qui on doit le fameux le
fabuleux les chatouilles qui est un
fruit qui avait beaucoup touché il
s'appelle de nouveau s'appelle quand tu
seras grand et oui voilà il est
réalisateurs reviennent et nous plonge
dans le quotidien cette fois-ci d'un
EHPAD se retrouve obligé d'accueillir
une classe d'enfants en panne de cantine
alors à cause de cette cohabitation
forcer les habitudes forcément des uns
et des autres vont se retrouver
bouleversés pour le meilleur comme pour
le pire et au fil du temps les tensions
du début vont donner lieu à des
rencontres touchantes les liens entre
générations vont venir déjouer un
sentiment de solitude pesant comme on
peut le savoir chez les pensionnaires et
les enfants réconforts bienveillance et
générosité humaine vont côtoyer la
violence institutionnelle et l'isolement
le tout bordé d'humour et de tendresse
on regarde un extrait
ils s'en foutent de moi
si résidents sur 10 n'ont jamais de
visite ses enfants c'est une chance de
les avoir
[Musique]
un truc
et on termine
c'était une pièce de théâtre avec Éric
métayer
le défi
et je le dis les le premier film du
château il a été
absolument formidable
on termine le troisième et dernier film
qui est votre choix c'est une comédie
qui fait un peu peur et dans laquelle on
peut retrouver Joachim Phoenix tout à
fait je vous préviens ce film est un
petit peu spécial Harry Aster nous
plonge dans un trip drôle et
hallucinatoire où l'on suit les
aventures de Bow Waterman un homme
paranoïaque et angoissé interprété
justement par Joachim Phoenix cet homme
perturbé et associal n'a qu'une seule
personne dans sa vie c'est sa mère qu'il
va tenter désespérément de rejoindre
tout au long du film mais c'est sans
compter sur du multiple catastrophes
burlesques qui vont venir perturber sa
quête il va se retrouver renverser
poignardée accusé juger et j'en passe
une présentation un peu chaotique et
surtout très métaphorique de son esprit
et du monde absurde dans lequel nous
évoluons
et puis on termine avec le cinéma avec
un film alors beaucoup plus classique
c'est le c'est le coup de cœur de du
d'un autre réalisateur qui s'appelle
gothibara qui est versaillé et qui va
nous parler d'un film culte c'est le kit
de Charlie Chaplin
[Musique]
je vais vous parler aujourd'hui du film
The Kid de Charlie Chaplin
connu sur le nom de chat Spencer Chaplin
il a été réalisé en 1921 donc par lui il
a été producteur également il a été
interprète du film
on peut parler ici d'une comédie
américaine
mais aussi d'un drame pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'on part sur une
histoire qui raconte la vie d'une femme
qui n'arrive plus à faire à vivre elle
et son enfant du coup elle va décider
tout simplement d'abandonner cette
enfant
ne sachant que faire et du coup chaque
Chaplin va tomber sur cet enfant il faut
pas oublier que je récapine joue
régulièrement le rôle du vagabond le
vagabond qui n'a pas de sous qui essaye
de se battre pour vivre pour avoir un
toit pour avoir à manger et un travail
il va concrètement se créer une relation
entre cet enfant et Charlie Chaplin
[Musique]
il faut savoir que Charlie Chaplin du
coup va lui apprendre tout ça toute la
vie il va lui apprendre
comment ça se passe quand quelqu'un ne
marche dessus sur les pieds comment
travailler comment
se battre pour avoir à manger le soir il
va lui apprendre la vie de façon tout
simplement pure et naturel
on a
Jackie kugan qui joue le rôle de
l'enfant
de façon juste merveilleuse tout chante
émouvante
on va dire même pure et avec
tout simplement enfin ancré dans son
temps c'est à dire qu'à l'époque le
petit côté visage d'ange pur
on le voit on avait juste envie de lui
c'est le serrer dans les bras et Charlie
Chaplin va faire ce geste là va faire ce
geste de l'accompagner tout au long de
sa vie et va avoir une véritable
relation père fils
voilà
chatine signera également la musique de
ce film qui va ajouter encore plus un
côté émouvant un côté touchant et ici
ici ce qu'on appelle une œuvre du 7e
tout simplement
ancré dans son temps en créant encore
aujourd'hui
toujours aussi mouvante toujours aussi
touchante et
il va réussir du coup une fois de plus à
nous donner beaucoup d'émotions tout
simplement avec sa part de muet
un film qui pourrait se résumer par deux
mots
tout simplement une larme et un sourire
[Musique]
très jolie formule de Gauthier
vous connaissez la petite fille
Un dîner presque français qu'on a pas
réussi à finir à faire d'ailleurs on a
fait juste quelques teaser ensemble
c'est de le reste à plat qui
s'entraîne une bonne relation et c'est
vrai que c'était c'était sympa de
l'avoir dans mon premier projet c'était
il y a il y a plus de 10 ans du coup
quand j'ai vu ça ça m'a fait penser
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup Céline Charles un petit
coup d'oeil avant de se quitter votre
sur la météo ça vous intéresse le temps
qu'il va faire demain on va regarder
[Musique]
alors voyez le matin c'est pas bon c'est
pas très gai je suis à peu près 10
degrés il faut se couvrir un petit peu
quand même
enfin c'est nuageux et puis l'après-midi
l'après-midi il y a de la pluie la pluie
c'est pas bien il faut et après c'est
très bien parce qu'il a pas assez plus
pour les agriculteurs donc c'est très
bien qu'il pleuve un peu et en plus
fraces 17 degrés donc c'est pas si mal
voilà cette édition du 78 est terminée
demain vous retrouverez une nouvelle
édition avec Nadine Rollès merci à tous
et à très vite
[Musique]